[Music]
[Music]
there are more of us now than there have
ever been
we number nearly 4 billion
the world population will double in less
than 35 years if we continue to multiply
continue to add more people to a planet
already unable to feed those of us alive
today
[Music]
only in recent years have governments
educators and concerned individuals
taken a closer look at the
inter-reacting parts that when assembled
portray a total image
a picture of the future unpleasant to
contemplate
[Music]
[Music]
demography
the study of human populations has
become an increasingly important tool
for the examination of alternative
futures
the accelerating dizzying speed with
which the planet is overpopulating must
be paralleled by a similar growth in
monitoring of statistics and their
accessibility
[Music]
the ever-present computer the machine
that now seems destined to be man's
constant companion can be designed and
programmed to provide instant electronic
answers about where we have been
where we are
and where we may be going
[Laughter]
[Music]
information statistics curves
probabilities knowledge can all be
collected culled collated and
transformed into an electronic memory
available at a touch
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the computer-based education
research laboratory at the university of
illinois in urbana where the computer
plato is located
plato's demographic program is provided
by the population dynamics group headed
by dr paul handler
the first plato was born here in 1959
[Music]
this is the heart of plato four
plato is a fourth generation computer
assisted instructional system
today's great grandson reflects the
refinements of years of experimentation
and design sophistication
[Music]
plato is an acronym for programmed logic
for automatic teaching operation
but he seems a person nonetheless
[Music]
the system comes to life as a plasma
display
a quarter million points of light give
him the easy ability to translate
information from computer memory to
visual display a display activated and
changed by a touch on a keyboard
the only umbilical linking plato with
his display terminals is a telephone
line
[Music]
the imperturbal plato can simultaneously
communicate with more than 500 display
terminals located throughout the united
states
contained in his electronic memory are
more than 100 courses for teaching and
reference
the population dynamics group is
constantly expanding and updating
demographic programs for plato
statistics are instantly available for
more than 100 countries
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
plato can display a number of conditions
using a variety of data into any program
looking toward the future
with data such as this the inquisitive
demographer can create alternative
futures for any country
how do demographics function
the population dynamics group exercising
a bit of playful programming introduces
a computerized ground zero
plato carries a ringer in his memory
banks
a mythical country
it is called delta
[Music]
delta is created out of whole cloth
let's assume in 1964.
however delta has no people
for a programmer and his computer this
is no problem
plato is asked to provide an instant
population
between 1965 and 1970 delta acquires a
population of 10 million children all
under age 5.
no adults just a miraculous appearance
of babies
the 1970 delta census shows a population
of nine million four hundred thousand
all children are age zero to four
some of the 10 million babies have died
even with a mythical country plato has
factored in an infant mortality rate
[Music]
delta's population is monitored as these
imaginary individuals grow up living out
their lives in seconds
in 1975 the group is aged five to nine
more have died
in 1980 the number is down again
now in 1985 the daltons are all 15 to
19.
at age 20 the females will be entering
an arbitrarily designated childbearing
period
also arbitrarily the women of delta will
each have four live births by the time
they are 29.
suddenly it's 1990 all women are 20 to
24 years old
children have begun to arrive
by 1995 the women are having their
second and third children
the number of children zero to four is
nearly twice the number of youngsters
aged five to nine
the delta women are taken out of their
child bearing period at age 30
but the women under 30 are still having
children
in the year 2000 all of the original
women are out of their child bearing
period
all children in delta are aged from zero
to fourteen
no children are born during the next
five year period
the first children are now 15 to 19.
during the next five year period from
2005 to 2010 they move into childbearing
age
now in 2010 the first grandchildren have
begun to appear
moving through the next 20 years finally
the original infant settlers are now 65
to 69 their children are 35 to 49.
the grandchildren and
great-grandchildren range in age from
zero to 29.
[Music]
20 years later the founders are now 85
and older they have nearly died out
but by now in only 90 years delta has
grown from 10 million babies to more
than 95 million people of all ages
delta is not a real country
but the chronological march through time
with the attendant reproductive cycle of
its people
is all too real
perhaps conservatively so
[Music]
plato can compare the populations and
age compositions of two countries
one of the highest population growth
rates in latin america is that of mexico
where the fertility rate is more than
six births
japan like most industrialized nations
is moving towards stabilizing its growth
japanese woman on the average gives
birth to only about two children
this is mexico's age composition in 1970
the total population is a bit more than
50 million
as in the mythical country of delta
there are about 10 million children in
the zero to four age cohort
in the last 30 years the mexican
population has grown very rapidly
plato can provide details about the
mexican age composition
how many children are zero to 14 years
old
the answer is approximately 23 million
46 percent of the population
this can be contrasted with the same age
group in japan
percentage-wise there are fewer of these
children in the japanese population
this indicates a significantly different
family size composition
japan shows a somewhat diminished number
of people in the 50 to 54 year old age
group this is due to the casualty
suffered during world war ii
[Music]
the 20 to 24 year old cohort is quite
large these are the people conceived in
the late 1940s after the men came home
in 1948 japan passed a liberal abortion
law
as a result the next youngest group now
aged 15 to 19 is smaller
the 10 to 14 group is smaller still
five to nine is about the same size
the newest cohort is larger not because
japanese women have increased their
fertility rate but because there are
more parents in this child-bearing age
group
a tale of two countries
in both the number of children zero to
four is about 10 million but japan's
population is twice that of mexico
in japan there is one child for every
two adults in mexico the dependency rate
is twice that one child for each adult
what does this mean to the trained
observer
for mexico more than twice the
educational cost load for adults
just to maintain current educational
levels mexico will have to build and
staff schools at an expansion rate of
three and one half percent per year
increasing the enrollment rate to
achieve universal education would call
for even higher costs
more people means that more of
everything will be needed
[Music]
more people is more mouths to feed
the population of colombia is increasing
at a rate of more than three and a half
percent a year
at this rate the population will double
in about 20 years
today colombian women give birth to more
than six children
the average life expectancy is nearly 60
years
how many mouths will there be to feed in
less than 60 years given no change in
the fertility rate and life expectancy
this projection assumes no improvement
in the 1970 national diet
plato indicates that by 2030 the demand
for food will be eight to nine times the
1970 total
what are the alternatives
plato was asked to forecast what would
happen if the fertility rate were to be
reduced gradually to three live births
per woman over the next 20 years
with this reduction the need for food in
2030 is only three times the 1970
figures
reducing the fertility rate to two
births over a 20-year period the
approximate level today in the united
states and japan yields this level of
demand for food
food production would have to be doubled
this is an attainable goal
plato answers questions
unfortunately he cannot provide
solutions
computers have not replaced people
the final responsibility is still a
human one
the continued rate of increase in the
demand for energy is the most critical
problem in all countries today
with its rapidly increasing population a
country like guatemala doesn't have an
energy problem
it has an energy crisis
guatemala's per person use of energy has
been rising at a rate of three and one
half percent every year
this growth added on to the increasing
population will mean that in the year
2000 guatemala will have an energy
demand more than seven times greater
than in 1970
[Music]
plato is asked to reduce the fertility
rate from 6.4 to 2 during a 20-year
period
even with this threefold reduction the
energy demand in less than 30 years is
still more than six times the 1970 rate
another alternative is to ask plato what
would happen if the annual demand
increase rate is reduced to two percent
from three and a half over a five year
period this still assuming a final
fertility rate of two births
the answer is still a giant increase to
four times the 1970 consumption rate
what would happen if the energy demand
were held to a zero rate of increase
during the first five-year period
even with the fertility reduction
program the per capita energy demand in
2000 is still more than twice the 1970
figure
the possible futures of a country's
educational needs and costs are also
included in the material that plato can
draw upon
[Music]
primary education in bolivia costs 600
pesos a year per student
adding students to the system entails a
per student expansion cost of 7 000
pesos
only about 72 of every 100 children
receive even primary schooling
plato is asked what it will cost to
educate the children who will be born
between 1970 and 2000 assuming no change
in fertility or mortality
the annual cost goes up to more than 875
million pesos
what happens if universal education is
to be achieved within 15 years
now the total is 1.2 billion pesos
how can these costs be reduced
the reduction of live births to 2.5
during the next 20 years along with a
climb to universal education is
requested
the annual cost in the year 2000 is now
reported as approximately 410 million
pesos
the pesos not spent on expanding primary
education to accommodate a giant child
population can now be used to provide
other social services
populations are people they must eat be
educated and they must work
there should be employment for every
adult
peru 1970
the total population visualized by age
groups
this is the labor force the population
is 13.6 million
the labor force is 4.6 million
one-third of the total population
this number is low because of the great
number of children under the age of 15.
in industrialized countries such as
japan the labor force is nearly half the
total population
plato has asked the expected population
and labor force in 1990 assuming no
changes in fertility and mortality
in that year the population numbers 26
million
the labor force has grown to 8.7 million
from 4.6 million in 1970.
by 1990 one new job will have to be
created for each job that now exists
an immediate reduction in fertility
would have no effect
most of those in the labor force in that
year have already been born
the die has already been cast
what would be the
the population dynamics program that
plato offers presents demography as a
living reacting science
gone are the endless columns of
statistics formulas and time-consuming
searches for information
the programmers have already assembled
the data
plato makes it available teaching and
demonstrating
tracking generations as yet unborn in
trails of glowing light
[Music]
at the same nutritional level
by 1975.
you will need 18 percent more food
by
it may appear that plato functions as a
prophet of doom
casting baleful predictions of an
overpopulated future
he is only the messenger plato deals in
hard cold facts
using the knowledge and data embedded in
his electronic memory
information collected from official
records
then implementing the computational
power of the system
in my country
in the next 10 years
[Music]
by 1975
[Music]
[Music]
plato provides instant electronic
answers to questions about the future
he does not forecast the future
the machine plato 4 tells us only what
the futures of our countries and the
world may be
man must choose the path he will take
toward tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you